hi there steve kaufman here today i want
to talk about conjugating spanish verbs
uh why because i googled to see what
were the main problems people had with
spanish various websites discuss the
difficulties of different languages it's
amazing how we can find so much
information just by googling
and conjugation how to conjugate spanish
verbs was the biggest problem people at
least
mentioned and then they talked about you
know
ser and the star
poor para
words that in english seem to have the
same meaning but in spanish there's two
different uh words
and then they mention pronouns they
meant to mention subjunctives but
conjugation seemed to be the biggest
problem
and i guess there's two aspects to
the conjugation of spanish verbs one is
the concept for an english speaker
the idea that the ending of a verb
changes for each person
and that the form changes for tense
we have some of that in english but our
uh verbs tend not to change verb endings
tend not to change according to the
person in spanish they do and that's an
a reason why in spanish very often you
don't have to
provide the pronoun
because
the verb already tells you who is doing
it but the issue is is not so much
understanding that
accepting the fact that the verbs change
the issue is trying to remember the
endings all right
so
uh
there are different websites that
suggest different ways of memorizing the
uh endings of spanish verbs
the problem is that these uh conjugation
tables are huge because there are so
many different tenses and in each tense
the endings change according to the
person
so
my advice in learning conjugation the
conjugation of spanish verbs
is no different really than advice when
it comes to learning
a list of any information like the
colors or the days of the week
uh
or even counting
parts of the body
uh you can
every so often uh you know glance over a
list of these things conjugation tables
uh declension tables in those languages
where nouns and adjectives change
according to case
you can glance over them you can read
them in my experience you can think
you're learning them you can think
you've memorized them
and yet
you forget them you forget them very
soon after having worked very hard
trying to learn them and particularly
under the pressure of speaking when
you're trying to get sort of some
momentum and some rhythm in the language
to try and nail the correct
ending
uh
by trying to go through what you
memorized
is very difficult
so what i suggest people do
is that my feeling is you have to get
you have to get used to
the way the language is spoken you have
to get used to these endings so you
start to produce them naturally
and the proof that you know a lot of
instruction doesn't help
can be found in english
and so many non-native speakers who have
had 10 years of english at school
still say he do
instead if he does
in other words or maybe they get that he
does but then in some other situation
the third person singular which in
english takes the s all of a sudden
loses the s because they haven't
developed
enough of a
of a habit of saying it correctly
we can even see this in native speakers
of english
who have had you know um
schooling for six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve years probably have had
their essays corrected
probably have used english correctly
but
uh you know i'll take an example i was
in northern alberta
at a very small primitive sawmill in a
small town and it was just i was buying
lumber from them for export to germany
but the equipment was very rudimentary
and
and and the their employee there had to
go out in 30 below zero weather and pick
up four
you know
squares four by four squares pick them
up and move them to another pile and he
did this all day long
and i said to the owner there or maybe
was the guy supervising them i said like
how can you get those people to do that
every day
all day in 30 below zero weather and the
guy's reply was he don't know no better
he don't know no better this is a native
speaker
native speaker probably didn't have a
lot of schooling
but
while in school probably he was taught
how to say he doesn't but be why does he
say he don't know no better because
that's what he hears around him
that's what he's picked up on
that's why people today are starting to
say
i would have went
instead of i would have gone i would
have came instead of i would have come
so
what we are surrounded with what we hear
all the time what we read oh if we read
this is what forms our language habits
so when it comes to
spanish conjugations
uh there is a tremendous dictionary i
mean there are other dictionaries but
there are so there are conjugating
dictionaries so when i'm on link for
example i looked up spanish on link and
people are going to get mad at me for
mentioning link but that's where i learn
languages that's my language learning
environment
and so i pick a verb
and i can choose con context reverso
conjugator so if i do that so if i see
a verb
and then i go to context reversal i see
the meaning but i see the full
conjugation of that verb so i go for the
one that i
am interested in or it could have been
uh something else in the future
whatever it might be i go and find it to
confirm to my mind
what that particular form of the verb is
and so doing a kind of glance around the
others don't try to nail it down and i
go back to the text of what i'm reading
and i also listen to that
so the reference to the table the
reference to the conjugation table
is part of the process of acquisition it
has a minor role i think we we
overestimate the degree to which we're
able to retain
what we
acquire while reading the table but it
is sort of satisfying to read the table
and you kind of refresh your mind a
little bit about different forms of the
verb that you have seen
but then you got to go back to the
context
read listen
uh notice verbs
while you're listening while you're
reading
and do as much listening and reading as
possible
and when in doubt about a verb you know
what is the
particular form here look it up look it
up a bit like the dictionary get in and
out
have a look at it look at some of the
others come back to your um
text
don't be too ambitious don't think
you're going to nail anything down and
if you keep on doing this
and if you give yourself enough exposure
you will gradually get accustomed to
certain phrases certain ways of using
the language which will be increasingly
correct including
uh being able to use on the fly the
perfect tense the future tense the
conditional tense because it'll be
within a context of meaning that you
have gotten used to so that's my advice
on learning the conjugation of spanish
verbs don't try to master it don't try
to nail it down
in my experience that's futile
refer to it occasionally and spend most
of your time
getting accustomed to the language okay
there you have it my take on the how to
learn the conjugation of spanish
verbs bye for now
[Music]
you